[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the peculiar object against which peer
insight directs the power of the notion
is faith which is the form of pure
consciousness confronting it in the same
element but it also has a relation to
the actual world for like faith it is
the return from the actual world into
pure consciousness we have first of all
to see the nature of its activity as it
is directed against the impure
intentions and perverse insights of the
actual world
here in paragraph 538 we are now moving
into a new subsection of this massive
spirit portion of the work and this is
called the enlightenment we'll talk
about that in just a moment but but
before we do that I want to remind us
that this is just a portion of the self
a Lea native spirit section of spirit so
we are making some very important
transitions but we're also carrying a
lot of things forward and the central
preoccupation of this entire section
that is how it how it is that that human
spirit as opposed to mere
self-consciousness or rationality spirit
itself becomes reconciled with itself
and that's not going to be a simple
process although it keeps on aiming for
it as if it is a simple process perhaps
not learning its lesson immediately as
we think it ought to but it but learning
its lesson in the way that it has to so
this entire section is connected with
the previous culture section and the
faith and insight that has gone before
now it is concerning the enlightenment
and enlightenment is something that we
should talk about a little bit you might
say that in certain respects what is
happening historically in this section
is near history for it for Hegel it's
actually older history for us because
we're quite removed in our contemporary
situation from the actual European
enlightenment but for Hegel this is
thinking about what has been going on
for roughly the past two centuries
really the last main century because
Hegel is writing this on well really the
first 10 years of the new century the
19th century which for us seems very
antiquated doesn't it but for Hegel this
is something very new and the previous
century was understood as in English the
Enlightenment in German the elf Clara
in French it's even even more explicit
the you know see actor Lumiere the the
the century of lights you know of those
who are enlightened and so there's
something really important going on here
now in a certain respect the history of
this is indeed finished by the time that
Hegel gets to it but in another way the
entire progress and project of the
Enlightenment is carrying itself forward
so that we we do see in fact some
twentieth-century theorists still
identifying themselves with the
Enlightenment as opposed to other
movements of history and ideas so what
what is going on in this very very short
section all that preface being given
Hegel is going to talk about three main
things here the the effect of pure
insight its relationship to the actual
world and this this other to it of faith
now both faith and pure insight as we
remember from the previous paragraphs
are involved in pure consciousness and
they are connected with each other so he
says the peculiar object against which
pure insight directs the power of the
notion the capacity for representing and
then going beyond representations
carrying out analyses the the power that
pure insight is deploying the power of
the dialectic is deployed against faith
against belief globba and we've we've
already sketched out what faith looks
like we're gonna see a little bit more
of this here keep in mind that the very
first section longest section of this
enlightenment portion is indeed the
struggle of the Enlightenment with
superstition so it is going to construe
faith as if faith is essentially the
same thing as as superstition so he says
faith is the form of pure consciousness
confronting it in the same element
why does pure insight have to go a
against faith because in a certain sense
they are sharing the same intellectual
space if we remind ourselves about how
we got here in the first place we have
the whole world of culture which turned
out to be quite a mess and pure
consciousness was something that
transcended that that moved beyond that
and then it showed itself as having two
aspects that of faith which had a
Content but which really wasn't
self-conscious and pure insight which is
self-conscious but doesn't have a
Content where is it going to get its
content well in part by turning
critically to faith but also in part by
turning to the actual world so we have
to look at what what else he says in
this paragraph he says it also has a
relation to the actual world for like
faith it is the return from the actual
world into pure consciousness so he says
we have first of all to see the nature
of its activity as it is directed
against the impure intentions and
perverse insights of the actual world
now those two terms that he's using
their insights on zigs
right that is what pure insight is
supposed to be but we have interested or
impure insights perverse insights we
also have intentions and this is
something that Hegel talked about in the
previous paragraphs this is a term that
he's going to use coming up in in the
next paragraphs as well so the intention
of pure insight is itself appear
intention but the intentions of
everybody involved in the real actual
world the world that we live in the
world of culture are impure they are
interested so how are these going to
play themselves out in relation to each
other and where is the initiative going
to take place that that does that second
one is easy to answer it's going to
happen on the site of pure insight at
least at first
how is this going to play itself out
well that is what we have to look at
next
we have already mentioned the tranquil
consciousness that stands opposed to
this turmoil which having once settled
down starts up all over again it
constitutes the side of pure insight and
intention this tranquil consciousness
however as we saw has no special insight
into the world of culture this latter
has itself rather the most painful
feeling and the truest insight about
itself the feeling that all its defenses
have broken down that every part of its
being has been tortured on the rack and
every bone broken it is also the
language of this feeling and the
brilliant talk which pronounces judgment
on every aspect of its condition here
therefore pure insight can have no
activity and content of its own and can
thus only behave as the formal and
faithful apprehension of its own
brilliant insight into the world and of
its own peculiar language since this
language is that of a distracted mind
and the pronouncement only some twaddle
uttered on the spur of the moment which
is again quickly forgotten and exists as
a whole only for a third consciousness
this latter can only be distinguished as
pure insight if it brings these
scattered trait traits into a general
picture and then makes them into an
insight for everyone
in paragraph 539 Hegel doesn't talk
about faith at all instead he turns
explicitly to the world of culture and
its relation to pure insight now he's
talking about it in terms of a tranquil
consciousness a holy got the voice sign
now why is it so tranquil and we could
say the same thing about the the
consciousness of faith because it is
pure consciousness it has detached
itself from the conditions of life from
the the culture that turns out to be
just a mess and a morass of
self-contradictions
insight seems at least at first and
we're going to see that this is not
entirely the case but at least at this
point in the dialectic it seems as if it
could be something that offers itself as
you might say a certainty if we want to
use Hegel's terms a certainty that will
also present itself as a truth to us as
well
no is this really going to be the case
we have to see here he says we've
mentioned that the tranquil
consciousness stands opposed to this
turmoil the turmoil of the world of
culture the world of culture is as we
have seen a world that has turned
against itself it generates as he's
going to say an entire you might say not
just language but an ongoing discussion
as a matter of fact ongoing discussions
and what we'll explore what kind of
discussions are involved in just a
moment about the nature and and the
extent and the adequacy of that very
culture and remember what is it that
culture is fundamentally about for Hegel
it's about consciousness attempting to
find some sort of recognition of what
the hell it is who who it is what its
purpose is and it's not finding anything
fixed that it can rely upon for good in
culture it's finding all sorts of
answers all sorts of options but none of
them turn out to be entirely satisfying
so he says the tranquil consciousness by
a contrast to that constitutes the side
of pure insight you know - on Zeke's and
pure intention
- opsi intention and insight are
connected here lexically they're both
connected to this this you know Zayin
and zipped this is looking upon you know
the intention is what you want to
achieve what it is that you're
attempting to bring about which in this
case is going to be what he's calling
this this general picture that is
available to all the insights shared by
everybody that we saw talked about
earlier in the faith and pure insight
section the insight that is going to
carry this out as a critical process
that is as a process critical of the
actual world of culture is closely
connected with this intention as a
matter of fact you could say one side is
the flip side of the other they are like
two sides of a coin so he goes on and he
says this tranquil consciousness however
as we saw this is a very interesting
observation has no special insight into
the world of culture that's something we
ought to dwell on a little bit this is
worth considering in several different
respects we often criticize philosophers
and philosophies and philosophical
systems as being overly abstract as
being removed from the actual world the
actual life in which we live and we say
that that doesn't really speak to me
right if we want to play off the
language aspect here because Hank Hegel
is going to be talking about language or
more strictly speaking speaking strata
right and Hegel is saying yes that's
right
pure insight doesn't really have much to
tell you about how you ought to live
your life
it sounds great the you know systems
that are available are wonderful you
read them you're like oh my goodness
this puts everything in perspective but
then you go to the actual world and you
try to actually apply that perspective
and you're at a loss how does this
actually fit what does this actually
mean this is a common experience it's
okay to have by the way to Hegel is
making room for this here in his system
of how consciousness develops why
because this is an integral moment in
the development of consciousness not
only for the individual but for human
consciousness per se so what doesn't the
tranquil consciousness get about the
real world so he tells us this latter
what is the latter the world of culture
has itself rather the most painful
feeling and the truest insight about
itself so notice what he's saying here
pure insight is not the truest insight
isn't the truest insight is coming
through the world of culture about
itself the real world the actual world
the world that people live in as
individuals Hegel never loses sight of
that that world has the purest insight
into itself and what is that insight
well that happened long before the faith
and pure insight section that we've just
gone through that happened in the entire
culture section all of this is [ __ ]
but all of this is what we've got
and it seems contingent and yet we can
find necessary reasons in it for why
things develop the way they did and it's
what's
confronting us what are we gonna do
about it wow I can I can actually choose
to do something that might be an
innovative or a creative move in this
but that's simply going to founder into
a kind of nothingness at some point as
well these are the truths that culture
tells itself about itself the noble
consciousness isn't truly noble the base
consciousness is an entirely base wealth
isn't what it's made out to be
neither is state power we can go on and
on and on the good and the bad shift
position this is what Hegel was telling
us and we might add all sorts of other
things about our own culture in the
present so Hegel talks about this
feeling and he says the feeling that all
of its defenses are broken down every
part of its being has been tortured on
the rack every bone broken that's a
feeling of despair but notice what it
also is it's a feeling of not being able
to remove oneself from that despairing
situation not being able to find a way
out a a path it's an aquaria in the
Greek sense right we might think of the
literature that we often write off as
nihilistic of our own time because it's
probably difficult for us to relate to
Sadie DeRose you know novel Ramos nephew
unless we've actually read it but you
could think about other things that you
might have read that capture that or
things you've seen on websites that are
part of this this realm of culture she
also goes on he says it's also the
language of this feeling and the
brilliant talk which pronounces judgment
on every aspect of its condition this is
very important it's not just a feeling
it's not just that sort of insight its
articulate it is a sprocket it is
language it is a discourse so everybody
who's proposing what is wrong with our
culture
not just our political culture but our
entire culture across the board and
pointing out its inconsistencies and its
failings and being told by other people
hey don't talk about that unless you've
got a solution all of that is what Hagel
has in mind here because that was going
on at the time of the Enlightenment as
well people who are in a one down
position and we're working for as we say
the man back then we're just as prone to
say what the hell is going on here this
doesn't make sense I'm a human being I
ought to live a better life than this
now here's where it gets really
important and interesting Hagel says
pure insight doesn't have any activity
or content of its own where does it get
it from then he says it can only behave
as the formal and faithful apprehension
of now here's where it gets really
telling in the language its own
brilliant insight but wait a second
wasn't that brilliant insight of the
person of culture that shape of
consciousness that earlier shape of
consciousness pure insight is taking
that on and transforming it he says pure
insight has no activity and content of
its own thus can only behave as the
formal and faithful apprehension of its
own brilliant insight into the world and
its own peculiar language its own
specific its own eigen language but I
thought that was the language of culture
now it's the language of pure insight
pure insight is doing cultural critique
and taking on what everybody else has
been saying about the culture but going
further with it developing it into
something more as Miller's you say
general but he should have said
universal right why why universally says
because this language is that of a
distracted mind and the pronouncement
only some twaddle uttered on the spur of
the moment that's that's what's
happening down here in the realm of
culture that's the the cultural we might
say the literati the people who matter
the people in the fashion industry the
people who writing the magazine articles
the people you know writing for the
fancy blogs the people who happen to
have been in the right position and who
gets to deplore this and deplore that
and say this needs to change and that
ought to change and this is no good and
we ought to advance this all of that is
twaddle according to Hegel but it can be
transformed into something that's not
just gibbering not just critique as a
commodity we might say it can be turned
into something more real than what the
real world seems to give us what does
Hegel have to say about this well again
look at the text he says this twaddle is
again quickly forgotten and it exists as
a whole only for a third consciousness
this third consciousness this latter can
only be distinguished as pure insight as
pure insight if it brings these
scattered traits into a general picture
all you - bill the universal picture if
it Universal eise's the representation
to build repre on to play off words here
a little bit more because remember what
is the world of culture the world of
building now we have a build a picture
or we might say a development and ethos
we might say as well if it can make a
general ethnos out of this and what does
it do
bye-bye attempting that it aims at
providing an insult and insight insult
insight that belongs to everybody he
goes on and he says may
them into an insight for everyone more
literally an insight of all the German
is just you know on Zeke Alice so how is
this going to take place we're not yet
quite there but this is its motive it's
going to take the world of culture and
take all these bits of critique all
these things that it's finding it's sort
of like surveying the entire field and
then drawing them into some sort of
systematized perspective that at least
in theory everybody ought to be able to
get behind
by this simple means that
clear up the confusion of this world for
we have found that it is not the groups
and the specific notions and
individuality x' that are the essence of
this actuality but that this has its
substance and supports solely in the
spirit which exists squad judging and
discussing and that the interest of
having a content for this argumentation
and Shatter alone preserves the whole in
the groups into which it is articulated
in this language of insight its
self-consciousness is for it's still a
being existing on its own account this
single individual but the vanity of the
content is at the same time the vanity
of the self that knows itself to be vain
when the placidly apprehending
consciousness makes a collection of the
most telling and penetrating versions of
all this brilliant talk the soul that
still preserves the whole then the
vanity of witty judgment perishes with
that other vanity the vanity of
existence the collection shows to most
people a better wit or to everyone at
least a more varied wit than their own
and shows that knowing better and
judging are in general something
Universal and now universally known with
this the sole remaining interest is
eradicated and the individual judgment
is resolved into the universal insight
however the knowledge of essence is
still firmly established as superior to
empty knowledge and pure insight only
manifest its own peculiar activity
insofar as it opposes itself to faith
in paragraph 540 at the beginning and at
the end Hegel says some things that are
a little bit surprising at the end he's
going to say that now pure insight can
turn its sights against faith which is
where he started you know in paragraph
538 but he's going to do that because at
least at this point the dialectic
between pure insight and the entire
world of culture has been resolved so he
tells us by this simple means that will
clear up the confusion of this world and
then in the rest of paragraph hundred
540 he's telling us how that occurs and
then we have a transition to the
opposition to pure faith so he says what
we've found is that it is not the groups
the maasen and the specific notions and
individuality x' that are the essence of
this actuality what's the actuality the
actuality that we're talking about is
this actuality that is being aimed at
that of a pure insight for everyone for
or for all so he says it has its
substance and supports solely in the
spirit which exists quad judging and
discussing as a spirit that is engaged
in judging and discussing discussing
what judging what well all of the
language that is generated by the world
of culture over here by all of these
interested perspectives and he says the
interest of having a content for this
argumentation and chatter alone
preserves the whole on the groups into
which it is articulated at a certain
point what's going on in culture ceases
to be critical and it becomes
self-preservation 'el it becomes a
matter of just talking so that somebody
gets to talk may be talking so that
somebody else doesn't talk and criticize
you doing your product making your
project right and Hegel is gonna go on
and say that
in this language of insight
self-consciousness is for it still a
being existing on its own account right
so we've got a transition from the world
of culture back to the individual who is
the individual engaging in insight and
he says the vanity of the content is at
the same time the vanity of the self
that knows itself to be vain we know
that vanity is occurring over here on
the side of culture we've already talked
about this is there also a kind of
vanity a kind of emptiness a kind of
pointlessness a meaninglessness to what
the individual is doing if it were just
the individual engaging in critique by
him or herself yes and this is in fact
the experience of so many people who do
engage in cultural critique who look at
the culture that they're they're
involved with and they're like this is
crap I can't believe that people take
this stuff seriously and they get on you
know social media or they write in their
diary or they they go out in the street
and talk or maybe they chant it at
somebody at the bar in a coffee shop
about how vain how mundane is the words
they usually use are superficial all of
this stuff is why are people talking
about sports
why are people talking about you know
pop culture why are people talking about
this where why is everyone interested in
the latest stroller for their baby all
of that is vanity if they're just an
individual on their own the realization
of that doesn't get them very far for a
lawn I mean they can be a troll on the
internet and you know oh you suck you
suck you suck you suck but after a while
telling everybody how much they suck
sucks itself right and you're like what
the hell is the point of what I'm doing
here Hegel saying that if you don't move
beyond that that itself reveals a kind
of vanity underlying it a vanity that's
similar to the vanity over here
so he says when the class of the
apprehending consciousness makes a
collection when it's engaged in the
cultural critique and it makes a
collection of the most telling and
penetrating versions of all this
brilliant talk the soul that still
preserves the whole then the vanity of
witty judgment perishes with that other
vanity what vanity the vanity of
existence Hegel was talking about neol
ism here isn't he so he says the
collection shows to most people a better
wit or to everyone at least a more
varied within their own shows that
knowing better and judging are in
general something Universal and now
universally known this is the transition
to the at this actuality that is at this
point just an ID allottee the inside of
all if you're engaged in critique so
long as it remains just your own
standpoint just your own opinion it
doesn't really matter that much it's
only when other people can also look at
it and say well they've got a point
there and as a matter of fact they've
put their point very well much better
than I could put it this culture really
is flawed there really are problems with
this you know think for example about
the popularity I'll use just one example
the popularity of South Park you know
the two creators of South Park who still
put in pretty long days doing it are
over here except insofar as they have an
audience that looks at them and says
these aren't just two trolls doing their
own thing and you know moving these
pictures around to say screw you to the
the prevailing culture it's because they
can respond to and say oh wow they are
right about political correctness they
are right about what it is that these
flag you know waving conservatives are
doing they are right about football
culture they are right about xenophobia
they are right about you know social
justice warriors things that people over
here say
but her being said better being said
more intelligently become the insight of
all now of course you know the South
Park didn't exist in Hegel's time and
the things that South Park is critiquing
for the most part didn't exist in
Hegel's time either but there's a
similar dynamic going on here that he's
talking about so he says with this the
sole remaining interest is eradicated
and the individual judgement is resolved
into the universal judgement the fact
that listen this is just my interested
perspective now moves into here and now
Eagle says something quite interesting
and this is gonna set the tenor for the
paragraphs yet to come he says the
knowledge of essence is still firmly
established as superior to empty
knowledge pure insight only manifests
its own peculiar activity insofar as it
opposes itself to faith so now we're
going to move into this you know as he
says the struggle against superstition
because faith is going to be construed
as superstition it's not as if we're
leaving the world of culture entirely
behind the actual world because the
world of faith is going to coincide with
it now but where this insight of all the
the you know what the individual insight
has transformed itself into is now going
to turn itself against faith so we have
to see where we're going to go and how
the enlightenment is going to take shape
and eventually take on some sort of
content
you